Harry Potter fans have spent countless hours
mulling over the books and film franchise
and have devised some pretty spellbinding
theories about the world of witchcraft and
wizardry, some of which have even impressed
the author herself.
Let's take a look at some of the most game-changing
of them all.
Muggles vs. wizards
Why do wizards have to hide their powers from
Muggles, and if they are so powerful, why
aren't they in charge of the world?
If history has taught us anything, it's that
usually those with superior firepower and
knowledge win in any matchup.
However, one Redditor had a different idea,
and it gives an interesting alternate explanation
— Wizards and Muggles fought a war sometime
in the Middle Ages, and the Muggles won.
In Goblet of Fire, it is revealed that the
Ministry of Magic has to talk to the British
Prime Minister about bringing a dragon into
the country.
This implies that the Minister of Magic reports
to the British Prime Minister and may require
his approval for matters of this nature.
Additionally, wizards of today appear to be
much less powerful when compared to ancient
wizards like Merlin, the Peverells, and the
founders of Hogwarts.
Perhaps the Muggles were more successful with
their trials and inquisitions than we were
originally led to believe.
The real Rita Skeeter
There were a lot of colorful characters to
come and go in the Harry Potter series, but
none felt quite as familiar as Rita Skeeter,
the intrepid journalist who would stop at
nothing to get her scoop for the Daily Prophet.
While her ethics were often questionable,
there was something about her prose that made
many fans wonder whether J.K.
Rowling may have designed the character to
be reminiscent of herself.
After all, Rowling is also a writer who also
made a detailed accounting of the non-muggle
world that feels very, very real to some readers.
At least one theorist has taken it a step
further and suggested that Rowling actually
is Rita Skeeter in real life, spilling all
of these well-documented details about the
wizarding world to us no-maj types as a means
of getting revenge against those who shunned
her from the other side.
"Scratch that last."
The secret of Horcruxes
One process that never gets fully explained
in the Harry Potter series is how horcruxes
are made.
Lord Voldemort was able to make himself a
bounty of these little life preservers at
some point in his younger years, but he seemed
to be the only one who ever had any backup
souls to spare and seemed to be unable or
unwilling to create any more once our heroes
started destroying them, so it must've been
difficult.
"This is very dark stuff, very dark indeed."
J.K.
Rowling herself has been vague about how they're
made, though she did once say that attempts
would probably be deadly for most wizards
because it's as complicated as splitting an
atom.
According to Harry Potter World UK on Twitter,
Rowling revealed the process to her editor
who allegedly felt like vomiting after.
This led one Redditor to surmise that cannibalism
may be involved.
Both cannibalism and the creation of horcruxes
involve stealing a life force for the absorption
of another.
The theory seems to have gained some serious
traction in Fantastic Beasts: The Crimes of
Grindelwald, as it was revealed that prior
to becoming Voldemort's pet and tag-along
horcrux, Nagini was actually a shape-shifting
maledictus who had a female human form before
we met her in the original series.
Voldemort may have killed off the piece of
Nagini that was human and swapped in a piece
of his own soul instead.
In defense of the Dursleys
When Voldemort tried to kill infant Harry,
a small piece of Tom Riddle's soul latched
onto Harry's brain and cozied up in there
for the next 17 years.
Even though Harry was not a "traditional"
Horcrux, we know that Voldemort's presence
affected Harry, giving him some of Voldemort's
powers and causing occasional angry and violent
outbursts.
What if Harry wasn't the only one affected
by Voldemort's presence?
Voldemort's Horcruxes were capable of dramatically
changing the personality of someone exposed
to one for extended periods.
Harry and Hermione were frequently snappish
and angry while carrying the locket, and normally
happy-go-lucky Ron turned into a raging, jealous
mess who abandoned his friends.
If a Horcrux can do that to a genial and good-natured
person, what might it have done to the Dursleys,
who were around Harry every day for ten years?
From flashbacks, we know that Petunia wasn't
exactly a very nice person as a child, and
Vernon was probably no better.
But it is interesting to consider that maybe
their already sour natures were further exacerbated
by Voldemort's evil influence.
Since Dudley was born the same year as Harry,
he's literally lived almost his entire life
around this Horcrux.
It almost makes you feel a little sorry for
them.
Almost.
"Wake up, Potter!
We're going to the zoo!"
Neville's clumsiness
During Neville Longbottom's first flying lesson
at Hogwarts, he earned a reputation as clumsy
and perhaps not the brightest student in the
new class of first-years.
There are plenty of other examples of Neville
being clumsy with magic and spells during
his early years at the school, but that first
flying lesson may not have been Neville's
fault at all.
After Voldemort's death, the Longbottoms were
targeted by Death Eaters and tortured to insanity,
which speaks to a definite animus against
the Longbottoms by Voldemort's crew.
When Professor Quirrell first tries to kill
Harry in Sorcerer's Stone, he does so by bewitching
Harry's broom as he rides it during a Quidditch
match.
The unnatural movements of Harry's broom are
very similar to what happened to Neville during
his flying lesson.
What if that arm-breaking incident was because
Quirrell was using the same charm to exact
a little torture on the Longbottom boy?
It should also be pointed out that, until
it was broken during the events in Order of
the Phoenix, Neville was using his father's
wand — the father who was driven insane
when Neville was an infant.
As we all know, "the wand chooses the wizard,"
and so some of Neville's early difficulties
with spells may have been due to him using
this hand-me-down.
After Neville gets a new wand, he seems to
grow in leaps and bounds in his confidence
and spell abilities.
Self-sorting wizards
In Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's Stone,
the Sorting Hat struggles with where to put
Potter, after the Boy Wizard kept thinking
over and over again:
"Not Slytherin, not Slytherin."
The Sorting Hat assured him that it'd be a
good fit for him but sent him over to Gryffindor
instead, per his wishes.
As a result of that scene, some fans suspect
that Harry may not have been the only one
who moved himself to another house.
One fan theory suggests that both Ron and
Hermione were also sent to Gryffindor rather
than houses they were suited for — Hufflepuff
and Ravenclaw, respectively — because of
their own preferences.
For Ron, the reasoning behind the choice seems
simple enough; all of his family was already
in Gryffindor, so he wanted to fit in.
For Hermione, it may have been a reflection
of her own newfound valor in venturing into
this whole new world alone.
Centaurs know all
There were two big scenes in the Harry Potter
series that pitted the titular wizard against
his arch-nemesis Voldemort in the Forbidden
Forest, and the first may have foreshadowed
the last.
As one fan theorist points out, after his
brush with death as a baby, Harry's first
encounter with the Dark Lord took place in
the forest, where he was sent to detention
alongside Hermione, Ron and Draco Malfoy with
instructions to find out what was killing
off the unicorns.
There he found a cloaked figure, which he'd
later discover to be Voldemort, drinking a
unicorn's blood.
Firenze the centaur scared the figure away
and in the book was then scolded by his fellow
centaur Bane, who warned him:
"We are sworn not to set ourselves against
the heavens.
Have we not read what is to come in the movements
of the planets?"
The centaurs didn't go on to spell it out,
so what we didn't know at the time was that
Harry's fate was to die at the hands of Voldemort
in that very place.
The centaurs pretty much foretold the final
battle before Harry knew the identity of the
cloaked figure that threatened his life so
early on.
"Just something to think about."
Protecting Snape
The Defense Against the Dark Arts classroom
was a revolving door for professors at Hogwarts
during Harry's time as a student.
First, there was a Professor Quirrell, who
carried Voldemort on the back of his head;
then came Gilderoy Lockhart, who was a fraud
and lost all his memories due to a misfired
memory charm.
Remus Lupin also walked away after he was
exposed as a werewolf, then Mad-Eye Moody
turned out to be Barty Crouch Jr. in disguise,
and Dolores Umbridge got herself dismissed
for insubordination and general wickedness
before Severus Snape was finally transferred
from his position as Potions professor to
take over.
"You know, I really hate children."
All the while, Snape seemed like the most
obvious choice for the role, and some fans
were left to wonder why he didn't get it until
Harry Potter and the Half-Blood Prince.
One theory has it that Dumbledore never gave
him the post to protect him.
The idea is that because he wouldn't let Tom
Riddle have the job years before, Riddle cursed
the position and assured that everyone who
occupied it would suffer some kind of cruel
fate and serve just one year.
Dumbledore refused Snape the job until he
made the Unbreakable Vow to kill Dumbledore
and thus resigned himself to a horrible year
already.
The theory might also explain why Snape, as
Headmaster, installed a death eater in the
role next, as he was clearly willing to sabotage
the guy on the sly whenever possible.
"Are you incapable of restraining yourself
or do you take pride in being an insufferable
know-it-all?"
Professor Trelawney was the real deal
She might have caught a lot of flak for her
histrionics, but Professor Trelawney was actually
on the mark with her prophecies a lot more
often than people thought.
For example, a re-read of what she predicted
in Harry Potter and the Prisoner of Azkaban
has some theorists believing she predicted
Dumbledore's death long before it happened
because she refused a seat at Christmas dinner
by saying:
"If I join the table, we shall be thirteen!
Nothing could be more unlucky!
Never forget that when thirteen dine together,
the first to rise will be the first to die!"
With Peter Pettigrew hiding out in the form
of Ron's rat Scabbers, there were 13 people
at the table, and Dumbledore was the first
to stand.
Meanwhile, she might not have been so wrong
in Harry Potter and the Goblet of Fire when
she sensed that Harry was born in "mid-winter."
Harry was a July baby, but what we didn't
know at the time was that a piece of Voldemort
was still embedded in him, and Tom Riddle's
birthday just so happened to be December 31st.
Some speculate her misinterpretation may have
only been due to the fact that her sense was
so strong that she was picking up on the Dark
Lord's date of birth instead.
It looks like Sybill Trelawney shouldn't have
been such a laughingstock after all.